we all think we can't live without debt
well you got to have a car payment right
and these student loans I mean you can't
get rid of these things we posted a clip
from my YouTube channel and it was about
how people making a hundred thousand
dollars feel broke and it's because of
debt it's because of their lifestyle and
he chirps and going this guy doesn't
understand that there's areas of the
country where you can't live on a
hundred thousand dollars and I went bro
if I didn't have any debt I could show
anyone how to live on 100 Grand in New
York City I promise you that when it
comes down to it let's say you're
effective tax rate effective tax rate
not marginal what you actually ended up
paying even in New York City was you
know 25 30 even 35 that still leaves you
with about six grand take-home pay they
love to complain about inflation and
cost of living and yes those are
astronomically high but I truly think
the answer is debt lifestyle and
lifestyle creep there's no control you
make the more you spend